is wind bender anime washing like
Japanese cartoons I don't think it's all
porn but probably a lot of it is right
mystical type storylines I don't know
maybe I'll love it a lot of breathy
action there the highball budget is off
the rails that's one thing about anime
sets unrealistic high expectations is
going down oh this dude is big these
robots are for sure gonna kill all of
them
he's got a big butt too but just endless
butts Oh as a Titan I thought that was
like shaft who's gonna be some hero
they're all like we need a run but
they're not running you need to get the
hell out of your town like spongebob
doesn't have this kind of drama in it
you know did anyone think to stop and
ask for a second maybe they're nice oh
we got save your mom the mom is just
like the debris has crushed my legs
this is bleakest oh this is so dark this
is so dark whoa he's got robot legs and
Moe or the jet pack comes in out of
nowhere
Indiana Jones just showed up why is he
blond what Doug he's this creepy ish hi
hello flashbacks to when he was a kid
just tears he's gonna eat her face off
confess her out of all the rubble and
found her oh come on you're kidding
right now tell me he's not gonna eat his
mother oh my god
Oh what are you kidding me just opened
her up like a like a cashew that's it
Wow that was crazy I want to watch the
next one though
I just assumed that all anime is about a
schoolgirl trying to avenge her father's
death oh they're not wearing anything
that is that can't be armor that's not
protecting her that much I don't know
what's happening there's so many colors
she's wearing suspenders over her
nipples
who's this onlooker I was like Popeye
looking she's super naked she's flirting
with some like spirit or something I can
see why people not me but some people
might like this oh oh
some Dragon Ball Z she's got a giant
scissor on her back I can only assume
that's some sort of sexual metaphor this
this will definitely cause seizures
defied my expectations more than it
meant what I thought anime was I I
definitely appreciate it more but I
don't know if I would watch it anime has
the option to be like really cool
kick-ass girls doing cool like what I
remember Sailor Moon to be and then and
then some people take it and ruin it and
make it like weird sexualized cartoons I
thought it was gonna be way more cute
way more animal here's what I love I
love the cinematography of the animation
like that first one especially there's
such movement such action it seems like
a big investment to get into just me and
the wife cuddling up to some smiling
Titans yeah I'd totally watch attack on
Titans I might go watch it tonight
you